So Stanley Milgram did debrief his participants. That is, he told them exactly
what the study was about and he made it very clear to them that they never hurt
anybody. But that's not to say that the study was without controversy. In fact,
remember that the participants really experienced serious and real mental
anguish and distress. When they thought they were hurting people. Now in fact,
only 5% of the people though, said that they regretted participating in the
study. But the controversy, was started. After Milgram /g, there was a real
serious debate, in and outside of psychology, about what was ethically okay, in
human research. So let's look more carefully at the ethics of Stanley Milgram's
study. So what is it that he first did, well, he first recruited participants
by telling them that this was a study on learning and punishment. And we now
know that was a lie, it was deceptive. But is that okay, is it okay in this
case? To use that kind of deception in research. What do you think?